easily goes right back to the inbounder
ketamine Ingram pop against O'Neill
they'll get it to Brandon Brandon with
two on the clock for the win
[Applause]
I was a kid
[Applause]
100%
to be in western comfort sauce though
now here
everybody celebrates and everyone's got
27 in 44 in the second down
you can't catch and shoot as we watch
the replay I said you would that's what
we say in the beginning of the game
[ __ ] shut the way the Utah Jazz guard
that pick and roll
Brandon Ingram understands you can
forego it so nail on me you can put back
down if it's on me
there's a foot jelly moves on me I can
feel get to my spot and elevate he has
been fantastic 15 and even better in the
ticket hands do you like it sighs we're
gonna like it a lot better when you're
in uniform next Wednesday hey man now
here's the problem
Gobert at the rib right and what are you
guys they can't catch it right and you
put everybody in front of the rim throw
it in for go oh wait a minute they're
calling a foul I believe on a hold
unbelievable they're calling a foul
[Applause]
let's see what it's all about they're
saying there is a Jersey held
potentially is that the case they're
gonna look at it this is ridiculous just
when you thought you had seen everything
right all right watch Jackson Hayes
[Applause]
oh my gosh no no no no no no no no you
don't want to take over a game they'll
just have no so Gobert has two great
throws you got it to win the game
[Music]
so Gobert can now win the game then to
put in top of the clock
[Applause]
are they going to escape again that's
what it boils down to
so Gobert is two of five at the
free-throw line tonight
61% on the season no time on the clock
so you don't need to fill the lane
anyway unless they put top of the clock
[Applause]
they're eager now win it for the Utah
Jazz and make it an 11 game winning
streak but now they do put two tents
back
[Applause]
[Music]
of the imbalance
bottom line we're going to live
get ready to box out
because you can get a quick tip maybe a
toe box out
Bradley's in there they were in the bag
[Music]
that it even comes down to this
he created the car
this divorce over time
and he got it second consecutive game
the Pels
are going to be going to overtime and
that'll do it five minutes
nobody's going anywhere
say Utah in great shape they thought it
was over with two tenths of a second ago